all right lookss like we're now live
going to start a few minutes earlier
than than uh scheduled because we've
already got some good questions lined up
here for the December 2023 ask me
anything session um beautiful drab day
outside here in Milwaukee downtown so
let's start with this first one which uh
is is pretty rich in terms of what we
can say by way of answer it's from
William Edwards do you think the word
evil has lost its utility especially in
political discourse where it's often
used to create a basic political divide
where is the conceptual use of evil most
useful for you outside of expressely
theological
discussion so no I wouldn't say it's
lost any of its utility except for
people who like to claim that there is
no such thing as evil or you know it
consists in demonizing your enemies you
know evil covers a a wide range right
and sometimes it's synonymous with
Badness sometimes it's understood as
like something distinctly moral there's
not just one kind of evil or one essence
of evil so I don't think it's lost its
usefulness at all and people have been
making this kind of complaint about um
you
know making out your opponents in
political discourse to be evil for
centuries and centuries so it's not it's
not something radically new so why would
that actually change the
usefulness of the term I mean we use it
in philosophy and moral philosophy all
the time you could think about um going
all the way back to the Greeks and
Romans we have the kacos and we have P
ponia wickedness and uh there's you know
sort of it's not as if there's like a
specifically philosophical and then a
specifically theological or religious
thing it's a blend a spectrum across
across the way and in religious texts
you're going to find people using evil
not necessarily in a theological sense
in Latin it's malum right and uh so you
know we can say that certain things are
in fact evil and it hasn't lost its
usefulness what it's you know if
anything and I I don't really think that
that our situation is much different
than 20 years ago 40 years ago 100 years
ago if anything um it's been sort of
like it's been turned into something
that uh people who are afraid to talk
about evil or who see people misapplying
the term evil get get all worked up
about and try to say oh we can't use
that term anymore but you know we don't
have to accept other people telling us
uh
that we can't use a term or the term is
no longer useful or anything like that
that's up to us to to decide um I have
zero problem saying that there are many
evil things and even that we sometimes
end up committing evil even if we have
good intentions or we end up uh
collaborating with or cooperating with
evil um and I you know I'm not going to
say that everybody should have that
particular stance but um
you might find yourself a little bit
Freer in terms of your thought and
practice if if you do so all right Henry
says I'm having trouble understanding
Till's conception of God as the ground
of being any thoughts or opinions on
systematic on his Systematic Theology
because there's a much wider range of
systematic theology also happy belated
anniversary to you and the wife so I
haven't read till for for decades
um I never found him really all that
profound um he seemed to be somebody who
is you know using existentialist um
ideas in what struck me is kind of a
more superficial way than many of the
other people out there whether
philosophers or theologians like himself
and so I never I never found his thought
really that interesting or attractive so
I don't actually have any opinions or or
views on that but you know if you w to
delve into his theology by all means go
ahead you know his his notion of God
always struck me as a little bit um what
would you say abstract and and
metaphysical rather than you know um
rich and robust in its its conception so
but you know I could be wrong about that
I I just don't think I'm going to spend
much time on till it given all the other
people I can spend my time on uh in the
present uh laps 9 Continuum Ben enjoying
your proma
videos and one of the prefaces to the
first critique K seems to suggest we
might have a kind of practical access to
things in themselves thoughts yeah I
mean he says that um in the uh
essentially the third part of um the the
uh groundwork to the metaphysics and
morals right um we are things in our in
themselves and so we're not just
isolated subjects but in our
freedom uh we can know more about how
things stand right we can't know in any
sort of scientific sense because that's
the world of phenomena but we certainly
can try to understand via
reason um what the thing in in our the
things in themselves that are us are and
as we could say locuses of Freedom as
things that have a will things that can
reason right um do do we ever get a
practical access to things in themselves
like objects out there in the world like
this cup which is a phenomenon K says no
um we we experience it through you know
perception bringing to Bear the
categories of the understanding on it
and that's about as good as it gets you
know we can we can like do science on it
and we can certainly have our practical
concerns like you know is it going to
hold my coffee and keep it warm and
because of its shape keep from spilling
which is why my wife uh ordered these
cups because I one time too many spilled
a regular coffee cup um K says no so I
don't I see that as kind of a dead end
um and you know maybe maybe we don't
need to try to get too much out of K
that isn't really there
is a broader idea with with philosophers
you know you with K you get the system
that he lays out and either you buy into
it or or you don't you know um but we
never really get access to the things in
themselves um not even in some sort of
afterlife or something like
that all right
[Music]
um Mark is here hey Greg hi everyone
hope you're all well have a good month
yeah you too man
uh Paul Jackson what is existentialism
or what at least is a good way to
characterize it was s right that what
the existentialists have in common is
the belief that existence precedes
essence no sart was not right about that
um and sart wasn't saying that it was
the belief that uh uh existence precedes
essence and he actually was sort of
kicking other people out of the the
existentialist um Spectrum including his
his uh Nemesis Gabriel who was using the
term existentialist long before sart was
and uh doing his work you know more than
a decade before sart s was actually
trying to take over the term and you
know you shouldn't use his definition
because it's already a polemical
definition um when he came out with that
haiger responded with the letter on
humanism haiger is a major
existentialist who's like well if that's
what you mean by existentialist then I'm
not an existentialist and same with
Marcel but why should we believe sart's
on this you know this matter
right why should we take his side it's
not as if sart was ever like the
spokesperson for existentialism because
there wasn't any existentialism is a
loose movement that begins in the 19th
century uh with with roots going all the
way back into
Antiquity uh so there's like what we
call Proto existentialists along the way
that include Augustine of Hippo and blae
Pascal and you know other people like
that and then it includes these
interesting authors like Surin
kard and um Fodor dostoevski Fredick
Nicha
arguably uh you know some of uh Leo
tolstoy's stuff and Henrik ibson and
August strinberg and um Al the strinberg
is coming a little bit later and um
check off as well right have definite
existentialist themes to them and then
you know by the beginning of the 20th
century we have you know Lev shesto and
we have uh Miguel D unamuno and Ortega
easset and we have uh uh you know these
great German language existentialists
some of whom are are you know not
ethnically German like like kfka right
um and um you know we have rer Maria R
and we could go on and on and so it's
not a simple thing and um we don't need
to give a single characterization of it
um let alone a definition what we can
say is there's these like themes that
existentialists tend to have in common
it's more like a family resemblance
definition if you're familiar with that
idea where we say you know there's like
about 10 or so different big themes and
not every existentialist will
necessarily uh embody all of those in
their work but these are the things that
tend to draw people through this and
what they tend to express you know for
example
philosophizing or theorizing about
things from your own concrete situation
um is that unique to
existentialism not really um but it
certainly is something that
characterizes existentialist philosophy
literature
um drama you know we could go on and on
and on right so um you know you don't
actually have to have a characterization
that tries to Encompass everybody and
that's counterproductive if you want to
understand
existentialism uh counting cards were
you a serious young
man um I was serious when I was a young
man uh but I also like to joke around a
lot so you know I think the question is
more like well what were you serious
about and for a long time it was uh
exercise you know and uh competitiveness
and things like that um I also was
serious by the time that I got to
graduate school I was pretty serious in
my studies even as an undergraduate I
could be serious about it from time to
time um I seriously wanted to be a
writer I guess I'm kind of a writer um I
was serious about um the relationships
and you know uh love affairs that I had
um some of the time and sometimes not
right so yeah but it sounds like serious
young man you know that's got that ring
of being like a moniker that somehow is
supposed to mean something big so I I
don't know uh propoline what was your
favorite book to read in your teenage
years I don't think had a favorite book
as such but I certainly did have a lot
of books that I enjoyed
reading um you know I I got into sci-fi
and and fantasy when I was pretty young
all the way in elementary school and
that continued through into my my
teenage
years um so you know Roger zelasney
Philip Jose farmer Ursa K Len were some
of my favorite authors at the time U but
there were many others you know Sten
Steven D you know I might be mixing it
up uh who's the guy who had the
dorsai uh stuff I really liked his stuff
and I like Keith L Mer's bolo Series so
you could say there's some military
science fiction mixed in with that and
uh Gordon Dickinson that's who it is uh
the dorsai or child series stuff I was
going to say Steven Donaldson and I knew
that wasn't right because he's a a
totally different author you know and
there were lots of like Lord of the
Rings spin-offs that I I kind of liked
um obviously tolken you know um so there
were lots of that sort of stuff I was
reading some kind of
philosophical works at the time you know
I think the f I mean the first book of
philosophy that I ever read was kamu
myth of Copus this but I didn't
understand more than like one tenth of
what I was reading at the time right so
uh all right
[Music]
um pipeline I saw John Verve series
Awakening from the meaning meaning
crisis and saw at stoican 23 do you know
his work and if so what's your
assessment of his philosophical take on
the meaning crisis so first of all I I'm
not a fan of Rea and I'm not a fan of
the mindfulness stuff either um and uh
so I'm not a good person to ask about
this the meaningless meaning crisis
that's been around for two centuries so
he didn't coin that he's just kind of
hopping onto that and using a concept
that many of us already had and have
been working with for a very long time
and he you know gives it a little little
bit of a Twist right um and there's you
know people like that there's plenty of
them out there doing that um I've never
found him particularly interesting or in
insightful other people seem to but you
know that's sort of like saying uh I I
like this kind of music you like this
kind of music because um you know
Different Strokes for different folks um
if you're into his stuff probably not
going to be that much into my stuff you
know um meta judge will you ever make
videos on Muslim philosophers probably
not because I've talked about this many
many times I don't read Arabic
um you know I like to work on texts
where I can go back to the original and
uh why should I do videos on people that
I'm not particularly well versed in you
know there's literally thousands of
people out there who could be creating
YouTube videos why shouldn't I stick to
the stuff that I'm I'm better at and
respect the division of labor and let
other people who are Scholars you know
of of Muslim philosophy
or Islamic philosophy why don't they do
it you know you should be asking them to
do it rather than asking me if I'm going
to do it same thing goes for you know
Indian philosophy you know everything
from the Indian subcontinent I don't
read Pali I don't read Sanskrit you know
I teach some of that stuff in classes
but I don't teach it as an expert I
teach it as somebody who has limited
competence in it same thing with
classical Chinese philosophy you know um
I learned little Mandarin but you know
that's not enough to be able to read the
daging in the you know original
classical Chinese uh in some sort of you
know critical addition so you know it's
smart for me not to do that sort of
thing because it leaves the room open
for other people to do that kind of work
you know all right
um re Barker question on miracles in
quotation marks not sure why my own
thought even if you see miracles happen
that doesn't entail a supernatural cause
just because something isn't understood
doesn't entail its Supernatural thoughts
yeah sure also doesn't mean that there
isn't a miracle I mean you seem kind of
dogmatic about this
um who's who's telling you that there's
Miracles that just because we don't
understand what something is that counts
as a miracal I mean Insane Clown posi uh
says that about magnets and stuff like
that but that doesn't seem to be what
most people mean when they say Miracles
oh I just don't understand it so it's a
miracle um and that certainly isn't what
it is in the philosophical literature so
that's that's kind of a non-starter
right there um but it sounds like
something you got to work out on on your
own
probably
um all right just skipped a little
bit here we go um met a judge what can
conception of the Trinity do you
subscribe to uh the trinitarian one I
mean you're going to lay out a whole
bunch of different options perhaps
because then I could pick among
those um William Zen says can you give
me some suggestions on how to do
philosophical detective work on
philosophers like you mentioned in your
video on originality like creating a
nitian theory of emotions so what I've
sometimes called philosophical detective
work as a description of what I
is where you take an author's
work and which includes very often their
correspondence with other
people and you you know you have to read
through all of it and study it and look
for the correlations between it and so
you can do this sometimes with a single
work like I've done this with stuff in
Thomas aquinus as
Somalia where you know like if you want
to understand this topic which is
officially talked about here you got to
look at these discussions over here and
here and here I've done that with
Aristotle piecing together you know for
example a a coherent theory of of anger
or how the passions play out and in um
uh social Discord what's called stasis
I've done a lot of this with anom I've
done some of this with Thomas Hobs you
know and um the way you do it is just
what I described you study their works
you you study their Works some more you
study them some more you take some notes
if if that helps you you like Mark
certain things you like start storing
stuff up in your head and then you get
fascinated with some sort of you know
topic that you uh think is within them
so like you know Nicha on now n doesn't
have a theory of the emotions you could
say a theory of the aects which is a bit
broader which includes drives and stuff
like that but I don't see a theory of
the emotions as such in N but if you do
well then start digging around you know
you're going to have to read everything
that you've got available from n that's
relevant and start um correlating things
start looking for the same you know
terminology being used and you're you're
gonna have to read it in the German or
else um it's not going to be feasible at
all so if you if you don't read German
maybe do Hume on the emotions instead
you know or or some other um author but
but you know
um that's basically what it consists in
there isn't a method to it there isn't
like some sort of like well first you do
this then you do this it's more like an
activity that that I do all right Ken
good to see you here in relation to
business ethics would you recommend a
specific business related place to start
or would you recommend delving into the
philosophy of Ethics in
general um so it kind of depends right
if you if you're like setting up a class
on business ethics which is a class I
fairly regularly teach and I I've taught
business ethics now I think at four
different
institutions uh and I've also taught
other professional ethics classes like
biomed ethics ethics for artists and
designers I've even done presentations
to like the um uh Wisconsin paralal
Association and I've done work with with
the uh with trainers with the American
Phil uh Psychological Association about
how to implement and and train people on
um their their code of ethics and
conduct so you
know broadly in professional ethics you
can say is there a place to start you've
almost got too many places to start so
what I usually do we've usually got like
a textbook and none of the textbooks are
really great they're they're all kind of
inadequate in certain ways
I've actually thought about writing my
own business ethics textbook that would
be in at least in my view a little bit
you know better put together than than
what we have
available um and then you you know I
usually assign some
articles and we we look at them we look
at the arguments in them so you know one
that we often begin with is Milton
fredman's 1970 essay the uh ethical
responsibility of a business is to
increase its profits and we don't do
that because it's the basis for business
this ethics we do it because this is
like representative of many people's
screwed up wrongheaded viewpoint on
responsibility right and so we want to
look at why people view things this way
and we usually start out with kind of
the the crappy theories first like
egoism or moral relativism right and
then we start getting into um you know
more robust theories like utilitarianism
or varieties of deontology or virt
ethics and ethics of care we hit
libertarianism on the way but that's
kind of a deficient
Theory when it comes to moral
philosophy um but then we read other
stuff along the way so if you're doing
like biomed ethics you're obviously
going to read stuff that has to do with
those kinds of issues and cases if
you're doing business ethics you're
probably going to look at like hiring
and firing and you know CEO compensation
and um how you treat suppliers or how
you treat customers and matters like
that um you know as well as like you
know who Bears the negative costs for
things that aren't really covered in
things what we call
externalities um but there isn't like
one one right way to start there's like
so much stuff out there that you could
dig into there's lots of great ways to
set up a business ethics class now if
you want to study it on your own you can
kind of like move around you know
there's 's a lot of great blogs out
there um there's people who specialize
just in business ethics and you can
follow them there are some people who do
business ethics and they've got like a
particular take on it right so like
Norman Bowie is a great example consan
business ethics and consan capitalism or
Robert Audi is another major
thinker um who I teach some some um
selections from in in my classes as well
um all right uh Anthony Summers I enjoy
heavy metal for music and style but I
enjoy the lyrics too I always found
Meade Death lyrics thought-provoking
what metal band explored interest and
Concepts in your opinion I mean tons of
them you know Meade one of my favorite
lines is actually from pells who's
buying I've used it as a motto um and
sometimes even in like uh meetings if
there's a new way I'll be the first in
line but it better work this time right
that's that's a uh
semi-round insight about social
transformation right uh we want things
to move towards the good we want to
reduce corruption we want to make things
work better be more rational but it
better work it better not just be some
you know Airy fairy make everybody
Feelgood kind of thing things better
work you know uh there's you could pick
all sorts of um metal artists who are
raising interesting questions problems
about The Human Condition about how
Society is set up you know when we ought
to be uh aggressive when we ought not to
be you know what what is valuable in in
life and all that sort of stuff so
yeah all right uh um Gary hello
Professor Sadler what are your thoughts
on Carl Schmidt's concept of the
political and more broadly as Hoban
Tendencies I don't think he's really
that
that that close to Hobs on a lot of
stuff and I think that Schmidt has been
kind of
oversold the insights that he has don't
strike me as really that profound you
know we reduce things down to friend and
enemy and we have states of exception
yeah okay so what um people have been
pointing that sort of thing out long
before Schmidt was around you know um
but you know he he he I think in part
because um he uh gets engaged with by
other Continental thinkers and you know
he had this this association with the
Nazi regime he gets a lot of mileage out
of that but the ideas aren't really that
radically new or profound so
um you know that's that's my take on him
uh Sean
Hamill I I've heard you talk in your
videos about being a mathematics major
What relation does mathematics have to
philosophy in your view have you ever
had an interest in the philosophy or
history of mathematics yeah I was I was
a mathematics and philosophy majored so
I double majored and there's plenty of
overlap right I mean you got the field
of logic and you got foundations of
mathematics and then you've got you know
philosophy of mathematics which is kind
of dealing with questions like well what
the hell's ma mathematics up to what are
its objects and sure yeah I got into all
that kind of stuff we actually did an
entire seminar uh when I was an
undergraduate spending a a a semester on
the book gerbach by Hof you know so yeah
there's plenty of overlap um where
people kind of go wrong is in thinking
that you're G to do more with math than
you actually can and this is a common
thing for philosophers I mean you can
look at Renee day 's uh early work where
he thinks that mathematics is like the
key to
everything um obviously doesn't doesn't
believe that by the end of his life you
know um so you know it's it's good to
study
mathematics um and you know when we say
mathematics it's nice that the British
call it maths rather than just math
right because we often use these these
big terms like math mathematics
science as if they name just one single
thing rather than a whole bunch of
interconnected things right um
mathematics is is you know
arithmetic and uh uh
computation and provin stats and
geometry and linear algebra and all
these different sorts of things that can
be interfaced with each other but
they're not all the same right and
different people specialize in different
areas of it um I got really good when I
was a math major at being able to like
see how to set up a proof or how to
solve a problem but as I got better at
that my abilities in in basic
computation started to flag and so I
would work with a guy who just like
could not see how to do stuff but he
didn't make mistakes in computation and
we were a great team together um when
we'd work on projects and stuff so you
know um I did I did a good bit of work
on on that sort of thing you know my
senior thesis was on isometric uh truth
self-referential statement groups that I
found a mathematical functional modeling
for and showed that they all reduce if
they truth self-referential and not
covering other variables either to the
Liar's Paradox or which can be uh I'll
tell you what it can be modeled as in a
moment or just to a uh
tautology and then my writing sample for
graduate school was showing that that
could actually be uh uh modeled
geometrically as a muia strip so yeah
lot lots of cool stuff ultimately I
found it kind of sterile you know
so all right ruly Bumble has a tricky
one here in what ways would you say
Christ fits or doesn't fit Aristotle's
conception of the magnanimous man from
the ethics or have any medieval
philosophers commented on this topic um
well I
mean the magnanimous man for Aristotle
is the person who within their
society uh deserves great honor and
expects great honor and so this is often
translated by Christian authors and
opposed by them as as Pride right not
being humble so it really depends on
what picture of Christ you're working
with it's not as if all Christians have
one single unitary conception of who
this Christ figure was and there's often
a lot of emphasis on humility which um
Aristotle does actually discussed to a
certain extent in the um discussion of
magn magnanimity in book four the nican
ethics but it's not quite the same thing
is what Christians are developing into
humility later because the humble person
for
Aristotle is not virtuous but they're
not vicious either like the vain or the
self you know the self-deprecating
person the person who the small sold
person um they demand little because
they realize they deserve little right
so and are there medievals who who talk
about this direct contrast between the
Aristotelian magnanimous uh uh you know
possessing all the virtues lofty high up
there person and then um Christ as a
particular model as opposed to just you
know other uh non other virtuous but non
magnanimous or non- prideful people yeah
I mean I think you can find discussions
in um you know medieval Scholastics once
Aristotle makes his way back in you know
the Touchstone for earlier medieval
Christian writers is going to be um you
know what they're getting of Aristotle
is coming
through
um uh people like Cicero and uh senica
who who are being copied out but those
those are eclectic or stoic writers
right and uh you know also to some
degree through Augustine although
Augustine doesn't talk an awful lot
about ER Aristotle right um and then
other other authors who do know
Aristotle uh sometimes even are like
aristotelians like John Damas right so
yeah there's there's discussions out
there um it's not as cut and dried as
some people want to make it out to be
like you know the Ancients were all
about pride and the great man and then
the Christians came along and they all
believed something completely different
you know way more complicated than that
I'd say
so all right uh Christian robbles what
are your thoughts on n's Will To Power I
often see it as a means through which
some people justify abuses of power n's
Praise of Napoleon comes to
mind um so yeah I mean people are going
to use and abuse other philosophers
Notions um so you got like three
different questions there actually what
do I think of nich's Will To Power I
mean I think that that's fundamental to
nich's metaphysics I think heiger is
right about that and um you know if you
want to understand n as an absolutely
Irreplaceable and Central concept way
more important than like the Eternal
recurrence of the same or some of the
other things that that come in with it
and it's a very complicated Topic in N
so to answer the second question you
know um I often see it as means through
which some people justify abuses of
power I mean do do you see a lot of
people using n to justify abuse as a
power most times people just abuse power
and find the easiest excuse at hand they
don't usually say well n says so you
must move in some very different circles
than than I do and n's Praise of
Napoleon I mean nche Praises all sorts
of people who cares you know um are you
saying that uh Napoleon was a bad guy
and you know abused power I mean in a
certain sense from a Nichi in
perspective you can't really abuse power
right if you have the power That's What
Makes You powerful you find out because
you dominate other people so you know to
to criticize uh n from that perspective
is sort of like what n does with the
stoics criticizing them for not being
him you know uh so that to me that's
kind of a uh as I another term I used
earlier a non-starter
right uh AR how would you know that
you're in love and how can you be in
love with someone and still have doubts
about them in a relationship I mean
let's answer the second question first
how can you be in love and still have
doubts you could realize that you're in
love with somebody who's a screw-up you
can be in love with somebody and there
could be all sorts of red flags this
happens all the time and you could be
like well this may be a tragic situation
where I love somebody and I wish that I
could be with them but they're a a hard
drug addict uh our life is not going to
work out great or you know maybe I
shouldn't be in love with them but I am
I have these feelings and I know that
they're an abuser you know uh or they're
a terrible person in some other respect
right that's that's not hard to Fathom
right that's that's easy we often
experience stuff like that um conflicts
between values and
emotions that's a lot of our life how
would you know that you're in love
there's no like you know single telltale
signs because being in love doesn't name
just one single thing there's lots of
different theories and understandings of
what it means to be in love um for some
people it's basically a euphemism for I
want to have sex with you other people
it's you know this selfless devotion
there's all sorts of other things that
that we call being in love and we
sometimes even use it of not just people
but like I'm in love with this this
music that comes from this band right
we're using it in a metaphorical sense
there so there isn't any single
Criterion for knowing that you're in
love but you know there's there's things
that function you could say as signs
that are fairly
traditional um you know we talk about
having butterflies in our stomach now
what exactly that feels like going to
vary from person to person right so um
maybe you want to look at at what other
people say about uh what being in love
looks like but I mean there is one good
question you know how do you know that
you're in love and not just infatuated
with somebody time you know does it wear
off um how long does it last you know
that's how that's one of the ways that
you can tell I mean if you do get to
have sex with them are you still in love
with them after you have sex with them
right uh okay boogie revery I've been
going back to Plato and some secondary
literature Plato platonist Thomas
Taylor's commentary seem controversial
to some scholar have you read them or
found them useful I don't even know who
Taylor Thomas is um I don't spend a lot
of time with secondary literature um
because I I have you know limited time
and I spend it on primary literature um
so I don't know who he is why his stuff
is
controversial um I don't have anything
to contribute there
um Gilbert Bates interested in
self-deprecating comedy is there a
relationship between healing trauma
vulnerability authenticity and turning
that into humor I mean there could be
there's no necessary relationship
between it right um some people could be
working on uncovering their traumas and
figuring out how to live a more
authentic life in Li to them and it
might have nothing to do with comedy or
humor um I myself find that it's often
helpful to laugh at things that seem
Grim or biting you know but that seems
off-putting to many other people
sometimes they feel like you're making
fun of their their uh
situation right even when you're just
like laughing about your own
situation so
um you know I don't see a connection
though between self-deprecating
comedy and healing trauma vulnerability
and
authenticity um self-deprecating trauma
could actually be the opposite it could
be about you know lacerating yourself
over and over again to please some other
people you know making little of
yourself so that other people can feel
feel good about themselves there's
there's no necessary connection between
them uh mul h d what do you think about
AI replacing jobs so a big topic um some
jobs will be replaced other jobs won't I
mean that's that's probably the the
easiest response to that um and then we
start getting into more specifics we
always have to ask well why would AI
replace a particular job what does it
supposedly do better than a human being
uh and then you know do we need human
beings to like check up on it and make
sure it doesn't screw things up
I mean think about the self-driving
vehicles um they're not doing too well
are they uh you still need you know
human governance in some respect we you
know there were all these predictions
that by now we were going to have
self-driving semi-tractor trailers and
it was going to revolutionize the
trucking industry which is in in a whole
other mess right now right uh having to
do with lowering um the wages and a lot
of the older truckers leaving it and you
know less and less training for younger
truckers and technological
transformation due to like you know uh
you know Governors and driver's logs and
cut off points and stuff like that but
we haven't seen a a massive replacement
of human beings with AI in that respect
yet we are seeing it in in other areas
but you got to be kind of careful with
the AI right
AIS they aren't really intelligent
and so if you're going to use it to like
um prepare your legal briefs as one
lawyer did you got to watch out for it
making stuff up you know and if you
bring it before a judge you might get
yourself in deep trouble and lose your
case and get brought up on ethics
charges with the bar association as a
result so I I think that a lot of the
the major predictions and fears about AI
replacing our jobs need to be they're
not complet but they need to be
qualified
considerably I also think too that maybe
maybe a lot of people who are like super
bullish about AI they're like oh it's
going to be amazing maybe they should
sit down and shut up right and maybe
also the AI doomsayers who are like AI
is gonna kill us all maybe they should
sit down and shut up too maybe we
should listen to the people who are more
in the middle and are not espousing
these sweeping assertions about Ai and
are being a little bit more careful with
what they have to say about it
right um Paul Jackson says what is the
relationship between gameplay chess
Sport and art a common response to game
play that was poetry and motion thanks
always I mean poetry and motion is a
nice
Trope
um but it doesn't really mean much of
anything anymore people have used it so
much
um I mean you could say that with game
playing there could be creative aspects
but art and the creative you know
Endeavors that we associate with it and
playing games are kind of two different
sorts of activities right they may
involve similar things like fluidity and
grace and beauty but um they have
different uh different points to them
right games could be about entertainment
they could be but it's all about the
interplay with the other people and
maybe they're you know they're also
about
competition um doing art appreciating
art you could turn that into games but
it's it's it's not a game as such you
know so I I don't really see that many
interconnections myself
um
all right uh prags Productions there's
tons of videos on Islamic philosophy
that people that ask just have to look
in the right
places um yeah that that's true I mean a
lot of times people ask me to do stuff
that other people are already doing like
you know um hey you did the half hour
Hegel series are you gonna do that for
hegel's science of logic why the hell
should I do that when step Holgate has
like an entire series on it with the
Hegel Society of Great Britain and you
just Google Hegel science of logic
videos and they'll come right up right
um so yeah I mean the people that are
asking for uh Islamic philosophy or
Chinese philosophy or Indian
philosophy there's plenty of stuff out
there I mean if you want good stuff on
Chinese philosophy there's Brian van
nordon you know um who when I'm teaching
that that stuff in my classes I have my
students watch his his videos right um I
don't have to make make my own for that
so all right uh vegan Sports parted
Socrates believe that virtue and wisdom
could be cultivated or that the amount
of virtue a person has is predetermined
so no virtue ethicist if they're a
virtue ethicist throughout history
believes that the amount of virtue a
person has is predetermined and as a
matter of fact most virtue ethicists
throughout time believe that uh you
don't start out with any virtue or if
you do it's at best tendency that that
were what Aristotle called natural
virtues so Socrates thinks that of
course you can cultivate virtue that's
that's what you ought to be doing right
instead of just saying oh well maybe the
gods will give it to me or nature will
give it to me right um so that's that's
a pretty straightforward one I I would
be surprised to see anybody who's
seriously reading PL Plato or xenophon
which is where we get our ideas of
Socrates
from somehow coming to the conclusion
that there's a predetermined amount of
virtue that a person has you know in in
Socrates
thought uh brother dullah have you read
much by Edward sahed and would you
consider doing a series on his work
orientalism the only thing I've read by
say is is his book
orientalism and I don't have any plans
to uh to hit on it in the future but I
will say this if somebody wants to
commission and what that means is
ponying up the money uh for the work
involved commission a series of of you
know core concept videos on Edward s's
orientalism then I'd be willing to do it
you know because people are always
asking can you do this can you do this
can you do this I already got plans you
know right now I'm doing a Manuel cons
uh proliga and I'm taking I am doing a
detour this this month I'm doing a
single commission video on Delo and and
gutter's um anti atopus part one on the
concept of the body without organs but
that's because somebody is willing to
pay for my time and energy to be taken
from one thing and put on to another um
so you know people can reach out to me
at any time about about that sort of
thing uh black prairie how does one
leave the notion that science is the
only way to truth other cultures have
their own ways of interpreting reality
but I believe feel science and dismisses
or discredits them as illusion so
there's no such thing as science per se
there's the
sciences and many of them are quite
different from place to place and time
to time so you know just we don't even
have to get into like the social
sciences think about the transformations
in physics in the last 200 years is
physics today what it was 200 years ago
does it name the same thing
no so there's no like capital S science
out there to uh dismiss other cultures
ways of interpreting reality and good
scientists don't think that science
covers all of reality anyway right I
mean there's plenty of great scientists
out there that you can read that will
say well we can talk about this and over
here now we're in metaphysics or
religion or something else right so you
know this I I think what you're working
with there is kind of a caricature of
science so you probably want to not be
as dismissive of science itself in that
way
right all right Patrick uh uh made a a a
uh super chat but and just says one um
so I'm guessing you know that's Praise
of some sort thanks for that that's very
nice uh let's see what the next question
is oh here's a good one Rexel uh any big
plans content wise for the channel this
2024 yeah a lot of the big plans are
like continuing on with the big plans
from the past right
so um I managed to finish the half hour
hegle project and I need to like
completely bring that to a
close um before I start doing other
similar close reading projects and the
next the next book that I'm going to do
is a short one um anoms prian which is
is a great great short little work of
uh Christian
metaphysics and you could even say Moral
Moral Theory to a certain extent and
then I want to do dart's meditations
with the same sort of careful let's you
know line by line look at what the text
is actually saying in uh ansel's case
obviously we're working from Latin right
in deart in the case of decart's
metaphysics we're looking closely at De
cart's own Latin text and the French
translation which is not by dekart of
the metaphysics and then the you know uh
sort of standard uh English translation
as well so those are kind of big plans
um you know I'm continuing on doing
these interviews in the ideas that
matter series with people that I think
have something really interesting to
contribute got a lot of guests lined up
for that um got uh you know a lot of
books to review I'll be doing more you
know personal videos as well um videos
about advice I've got a lot of core
concept videos on different thinkers
that I want to get to you know I
probably won't finish up cons proma this
this month but that'll bleed into
2024 and then you know I'm teaching an
existentialism class in in the spring so
I've got to uh produce some more videos
for that on certain texts and
authors
um you know holding events like this
um but I don't have any I mean I've
thought about doing like some video
essays we'll see how ambitious I get you
know with me the biggest constraint is
always
time um do I have the time to actually
get things get things accomplished
right
uh Muhammad says which book did Alistar
McIntyre talk primarily on political
philosophy there wasn't a book there's
all sorts of books um going way back
before after
virtue where he talks about political
philosophy sometimes he's reviewing
other people's political philosophy like
if you if you read his um a history of
Ethics it it is about ethics but it is
also social political
philosophy um you know he's got got
social critique in things like against
the self-images of the day he's got you
know all sorts of political implications
in the uh tetrology after virtue who's
Justice which rationality three rival
versions of moral inquiry and dependent
rational animals and uh he's got all
sorts of great essays in in his selected
essays I think uh volume two is on
ethics and politics if I remember right
so there there'd be a lot of stuff in in
there as well and that you know that's
already a lot but that'll get you going
right um all right uh laps n Continuum
do you think
participating in an online grad program
might be better or worse in any way than
going to classes in person totally
depends on the program totally depends
on the student some people don't do well
in online settings you know and they
really need that personal face-to-face
interaction some people do better in
online settings you know um and the good
thing about online settings is you can
you can do it from anywhere right you
don't have to have a residency there in
New York or Chicago or wherever else
it's going to be and so that's one of
the attractive aspects of
it there are some things that are harder
to do online but there's also a lot of
cool stuff that you can do online and
even you know like if you have an
in-person program there's absolutely no
reason why there shouldn't be a massive
online component to it right now like
you know classes these days if they're
if they're real classes they use course
management systems and you know so I
teach face-to-face classes but I load
them up with all sorts of you know
resources for my students including like
my videos and podcast episodes on the
thinkers and texts and handouts and
lesson pages and links to other you know
resources um so you know it's not as if
we have just completely online or just
completely face Toof face as a uh uh
modality difference
anymore um but it also really depends on
who's who's teaching right there are
people who are great
professors but they don't know how to
manage an online environment and so if
the bulk of the people in your
program don't really know how to use
online effectively it's not going to be
a great learning experience for you and
how do you how do you test that out I
guess word of mouth you know looking at
reviews and stuff like that would be
important all right
um John asks do you have an opinion on n
as a philologist or linguist right a
classicist is an interpreter of the
Greeks whether it be about the homeric
question the origin of tragedy or the
eological history of the word
agathos uh I think you know so I don't
care at all about the homeric question
that that doesn't interest me and I
don't have an opinion on it but the
origin of tragedy I mean I do I think n
has got it completely right no but it's
pretty damn insightful in a lot of ways
right um and well worth thinking about
um and uh theological history of the
word agathos and it's also Associated
things because it's not just agathos
it's esos it's all all sorts of other
value terms that are being used there um
do we know if he's right about that not
really but he's telling an interesting
plausible story that figures importantly
into his moral theory but you can always
ask okay so if he's wrong about this
point or that point what what happen
happens to the overall Theory does it
all fall apart or could he still be
right about you know different kinds of
morality and you know the more
complicated way things play out in like
essay 2 and Essay 3 of the
genealogy um if if you know it's not
completely clear that this is the case
because of linguistics so those are
things to bear in mind I would
say
um Alan hussy have you engaged much with
Del if so I was wondering your thoughts
on his conception of difference um yeah
I mean I've been reading Delo since I
was an
undergraduate um I prefer Delo to Delo
and gari I think that while they were
great friends qari is in a certain sense
a bad influence on him and the works
that they write together are more like
you know free association of ideas and I
think delus is a more careful thinker
when he's doing his own history of
philosophy or like the logic of sense or
you know essays uh critical and clinical
and I've done videos on Duo so you you
know that I've actually uh you know
engaged with Delo because they're
they're there in the
channel
um I think that when it comes to a lot
of
Concepts um in Continental philosophy
late Continental philosophy they're
often poor poorly defined and wind up
the the word ends up doing a lot of work
right so difference what the hell
exactly does that mean well it means
this and this place and this and this
place and this and this place same thing
with dairy D too by the way oh there's
difference and difference right and one
is with an A and one is with an e and
you're like all right at a certain point
this gets a little too precious you know
and it's it's sort of like this is what
the uh fans are really into but what can
you actually do with that can you can
you operationalize this in some way so
that you can get something done I mean
Delo talks about you know philosophy is
about making Concepts you know at a
certain point you you got enough
Concepts and you don't need to make any
more and you should like stick with the
ones that you got and explain them a bit
better you know and this is one of the
weaknesses I think not just of Del lose
but like that whole generation of of
Continental theorists I would say you
know so much experimentation so much
like you know pushing the envelope not
enough systematic work saying what the
hell did I say back there and how does
that connect to this am I actually being
consistent you know which tends to be
less you know sexy less attractive less
less interesting and I think that these
these sort of ideas catch on with a lot
of people because they can you know make
them do whatever they want I mean body
without organs is another one of those
things you can put together a coherent
concept of it but go to just about
anybody who is is into toose and say
what does the body without organs
actually mean and they'll like often
spout Passages at you and you're like
that isn't what I'm asking you for what
does it actually mean what can we
circumscribe the concept so we can
actually do something with it or is it
just like a a cool thing to say you know
all right Bartholomew says have you read
any Julius avola no I haven't I haven't
read any aola at this point in time I
probably will down the line because I
want to see what sort of nonsense
he's on and you know the people
that I see bringing him up usually are
crackpots or you know pretty pretty
gross people um and uh I kind of want to
know what what what he's actually saying
I suspect it's not really that profound
and you know I'm I'm willing to bet that
I'm going to read it and I'll be like
yeah I've already seen this kind of
stuff before you know it's not that
radically different than 19 century
traditionalism just with a couple other
things mixed in but I don't know we
we'll find out you
know um Luke says oh he's talking about
art with somebody else
um Stephen says uh been reading delus
and gari for a bit now and despite his
anti- hegelian stance I noticed some
similarities to what I think is subl
could you explain that concept uh so you
mean hegelian sublation so
sublation also translated in like a
whole bunch of other different ways um
the best way to understand it is when
something is being Al you know alcoban
sublated what what is essential in it is
being carried forward into a higher um
higher state and the stuff that's
inessential is being kind of left behind
behind and it's um it's being
transformed in the process but it's also
being preserved in the
process um now is there something like
that in Delo and gari I mean there's
something like that in just about
everybody we call that synthesizing
things we call that like interpreting
right so
um I mean anti-gel
ISM very often same thing with kard
right
is not so much being
anti-hel it's being it's responding to
the people of the time who are doing
things in kind of a cookie cutter way
with hegel's thought right Hegel was a
very um important thinker for Mid 20th
century French philosophers because you
got the existentialists who are you know
reacting against Hegel but also
sometimes incorporating Hegel um you
know for example you see some de buir
and John Paul sart talking about um
Hegel in in their Works um then you got
the marxists who are you know
rediscovering Hegel and saying the clue
to understanding Marx is understanding
uh or at least early marks is
understanding Hegel and can we bring
these together so right you got those
those types and then you know you've got
um the
structural um Linguistics and and
anthropology people and they're probably
Hegel less but sometimes they get a
little fascinated with him as well so
it's understandable why Delo and and gri
are are you know um viewing Hegel as as
problematic and there are some things
about Hegel that are very problematic
did history end is the whole system one
big closed thing or is Hegel sometimes
kind of you know kind of selling you uh
BS I I think sometimes he is right um so
that's you
know that's uh worth taking into
account
um let's see
here Patrick appreciate your work
question about G n's genealogy of morals
second essay why does he think the
questioning of the value of Truth is so
unanswerable and can lead perhaps to
suicidal nalism I'd have to go back and
take a look at that I I think that's
more stuff that's coming up in the third
essay than the second essay the second
essay
is really primarily concerned with the
origin of the bad conscience and looking
at how the early um like you know two
moralities which aren't even just two
because you got the priest as a weird
mix figure in there as well between um
uh you know Master morality and slave or
herd morality right how that gets
complicated by the debtor creditor
relationship which is economic but is
also involved in culture how the um
strong who aren't the top strong wind up
being subordinated and then having to
repress their instincts right and then
the development of religion in the third
essay we actually do get the the threat
of neoism right in part because n traces
out you know the the um aesthetic Motif
which is found a aesthetic rather
in first in religion then in philosophy
then in the man of science which by the
way mirrors um what the the
um um positivists like CT were were
saying you know the age of uh theology
metaphysics and then positivism right
anich is saying that science and this is
not something radically new in the
genealogy it's already there in um the
birth of tragedy that science practiced
consistently as actually undermining
itself and undermining values and and we
being left in this kind of wasteland
right so that winds up um being uh quite
quite
Central
um black prairie I'm going to start
reading the history of sexuality any
tips um yeah you know be kind of
skeptical about um fuko's narrative that
he's he's
uh laying out there it's a little bit
you know when you actually know the
source text that he's bringing up and
you you know you can compare it to other
alternate histories of Ethics which is
essentially what the history of
sexuality is um you you read some of his
stuff and you're like okay that's a good
insight and then other stuff and you're
like yeah come on that ain't the case
you're you're really overplaying it
there so you know um don't don't
necessarily
believe that just because he's uh
brought together some texts and told an
interesting story that things actually
are the way that that Fuko says that
they are I mean there's some interesting
key ideas that are being brought up
there you know's he's sort of
elaborating the Technologies of the self
idea which you you find discussed in
other
places
um and you know you got to have a
certain kind of patience with Fuko
because he does like
to throw a lot of material at you you
know
so all right
um Wen says what do you think about
Philosophy of Law what do you think
about the actual themes and problems are
I don't know not an area that I I
actually work in so that that would be
something that you should probably ask
somebody who's a a specialist in the the
field Paul says uh uh about uh I wrote a
paper on the topic
uh about art and Sport right um okay um
so I I that's good Quinn what do you
think about K's thing in itself are
there any ways it's still relevant in
everyday life I mean how the hell would
it be relevant in everyday life you
can't reach the thing in itself so and K
thinks you don't need to try to reach
the thing in itself so that's kind of a
non-starter right um it's uh I suppose
if people get really upset and they're
like I can't truly know what my cup is
or the coffee that I'm drinking but
that's more of a an individual
psychological problem than like a big
philosophical problem that would need to
be
addressed um so you know I'm not a
conscience so I I'm not I'm not that
worried about the fact that he says that
we can't really know the thing in itself
uh myself you know
all right
um Patrick says why couldn't you just
think truth is valuable because it's
useful for satisfying desires for
example I'm just not sure I see the
problem I'm not sure what problem is
being referred to there um there's no
one single conception of Truth and there
are lots of different theories of Truth
out there all of which capture some
aspect of it we often say like you know
correspondence coherence prag atic but
there's earlier theories of Truth as
well you know ands and his work on truth
truth exists in thought in language in
being itself in the will in action um
you know haiger has got truth as as uh
uh unconcealed and stuff like that so
there isn't like a single conception of
truth and you know some some truth is
valuable uh because it's useful for
things right uh okay so Patrick says I
meant NCH is the problem of the value of
Truth there isn't a single I mean so
when you read n to say things like that
you gota like read into them um and you
also have to think about the fact that
Nicha is writing in a time where people
are very very very
optimistic about human beings capacity
through modern science to reach absolute
truth
right and that's being undermined and so
when people are wrongly committed to
thinking that that truth is something
wonderful and we can have it and then
you pull that out from them they um you
know they uh often are at a loss right
so there can be that Zachary asks
defenses against egoism charge made
against virtue ethics well I mean the
best offense is uh you know clearly the
people who make that charge haven't read
much virtue ethics you know Aristotle is
not an egoist uh the stoics aren't
egoists Plato's not an egoist just being
you Aristotle has like a whole
discussion of being
self-centered a lover of self literally
in the right ways and the wrong ways in
nickol McCain ethics book nine um so a
lot of the people that are making those
sort of charges you don't have to take
them that seriously because they don't
know what the hell they're talking about
right um you ask them well what do you
actually mean by egoism and how do you
see it applying in in these ethics I
mean clearly there's an other centered
direction to you know classical virtue
ethics um so where are you getting this
from are are you like reading
contemporary reconstructions of virtue
ethics that have nothing to do with
Aristotle or the stoics or or you know
middle platonist like Plutarch or
Christian virtue ethicist like
Augustine um or are you actually reading
the the the the authors who are virtue
ethicists you know um because it's
pretty hard to find you know much egoism
in the sense of like everybody should be
selfish and you should always Place
yourself first when Aristotle says you
know Justice is a virtue and Justice is
the whole of virtue because it's all of
the it's each of the virtues directed
towards another person right so um I
think I think a lot of the people that
you'd be worried about there just don't
know what they're talking about right uh
all right coming back muhamed says who
in your opinion are the best five
philosophers now I wouldn't I wouldn't
have any idea you know um and I don't
really worry about best or rankings or
stuff like that
myself Quinn um oh I already did that
one uh Alis says what to do with the
loss of a loved one like a heartbroken
situation I'm considering
reinvestigating Plato's
Symposium well
um I don't know that that will be that
that
helpful um unless your goal is somehow
to transform the love that you had for
the Lost person into an
appreciation of more impersonal things
that's the trajectory in Plato's
Symposium with the ladder of love you
move from beautiful bodies to beautiful
souls away from beautiful souls to what
makes the souls beautiful namely laws
and institutions that shape the soul
which are now impersonal and societal
and then to the knowledges the epistemy
which make those those um you know laws
and customs and things work the way they
do and then finally to the the form of
the good or the form of the beautiful
the ocean of Beauty Beyond being I mean
if you can pull that off you're not
going to like be sad about your your
loss very long but you can also there's
you know you can think about the image
that you have of the Lost person
preserved within your soul senica talks
about this anom brings that up I've got
a whole article on on you know that from
years
back talking about anel was a
neoplatonist in that respect um and and
that can be quite helpful I mean I lost
the closest Companion Animal I've ever
had in my life
sassy uh about a year and a half ago and
I think about her every single day and I
do so in a deliberate way to keep her
her here in my heart and to bring her
with me to places that I go even when
I'm like you know taking care of other
cats but that's a a philosophical
practice that you can do
so yeah and and you know we we do encour
soon and the thing is with life
everybody we know is either going to die
before us or we're going to die before
them or we're going to die at the same
time so we're going to lose if we stay
alive for any given amount of time we're
going to lose people and learning how to
how to deal with that and you know keep
that what's what's valuable in their
their image or memory still with us that
can be quite good you can love that you
know all right
um Von says have a disbelief in
philosophical texts that seem like
someone high wrote them random word mix
giving the that seems deep feeling
without any practical use in life except
intellectual
Amusement yeah I mean that's that's
probably legitimate I mean some people
it is intellectual Amusement that is a
practical purpose in life but um and you
can be a little bit too practical too I
mean if you impose that on philosophy
the tendency is to cut off a lot of the
stuff that'll actually help you have a
deeper understanding of the philosophers
but yeah I'm not a big fan of the free
association string a bunch of jargon
stuff together myself either although I
was when I was younger you know and then
other people are like well what the hell
does that actually mean you know and
then I would be like well it means that
I wouldn't have an answer and then I
realized well I was kind of bullshitting
around you know um and that's part of
what helped me move away from some of
the Contemporary Continental thinkers
right um all right let's see
here Eric Mets what do you think of
there being an absolute truth as Jesus
proclaims he is do you believe in the
Divinity and lordship of Jesus where
does Jesus ever use the word absolute I
don't see that in any of the
gospels um that seems like a kind of
non-star hard to me right
um Batu if you could chat with one
philosopher from the Past who would it
be and what would be the topic so
assuming that like you know they would
speak English or I would have some
Universal translation device because
otherwise we probably couldn't talk um
you
know there's a lot of people I would
love to get to chat
with um you know today and I might have
different answers at different times
maybe I'd say uh Marcus too Cicero I
mean he got to study with some of the
greatest uh minds of his own time
representatives of important
philosophical schools he had this very
cool project of he's gonna like take
Greek philosophy and put it into a Latin
setting to show that you can do
philosophy effectively in Latin and he
does so while being a lawyer a States
person uh a family man sometimes having
to go into exile
you know fighting in a civil war so it'd
be pretty cool to talk with him I mean
he might not want to talk with me though
he might be like who is this peasant
what the hell do I care about Gregory
Sadler you know um maybe he'd try to
mine my brain for like you know what
contemporary Society is like or
something like
that um and Olivia sorry for the loss of
your cat and happy anniversary to you
and your wife oh thanks yeah married 12
years that's that's pretty good
you
know uh Andy and I have known each other
since I was 15 and she was 14 we met in
high school but uh we didn't date in
high school we kind of shared you know
Circles of friends she had a crush on me
but one of her friends called dibs and
then didn't follow up um and then we met
again in the 90s flirted with each other
working in the same office building
lived in the same neighborhood here in
Milwaukee but we were going out with
different people at the time and then we
connected up in the uh end of 2009 via
Facebook and then within a couple months
solely by writing to each other fell in
love decided we wanted to make a life
together and then only began talking on
the phone uh in March of 2010 and then
you know started figuring out how we
were gonna actually live together and
get married
so all right
um
hacker own member do you think there are
compelling Arguments for God if not then
what do you think is the strongest
argument for God I'm not sure what you
mean by compelling uh and strong in that
case um if something isn't compelling
how is it strong right but do you mean
compelling like everybody who hears that
argument must be
convinced um and it kind of depends on
what you think Arguments for God are
supposed to do I don't think that that
any of them really function in a vacuum
all by themselves to convince people who
are hardcore atheists that yes there's a
God I think that they work within a
fabric with other ideas and experiences
and Reflection by the person to decide
whether or not they want to think
there's something out there that uh
corresponds to what people call God but
there's a lot of different viewpoints on
what God is as well right
so um I think arguments can be quite
helpful that way but they don't do the
job all by themselves
right
um let's
see there's some cilc letters here so I
don't know how to pronounce this
person's name can you name any
philosophers theologians who can be seen
as successors to Blondell who are or who
are heavily inspired by his work for
myself I've just discovered Norris Clark
yeah Clark knows
Blondell um sure I mean there's uh
anonin certian right um there's the
transcendental Thomas like uh Joseph
maral who uh writes you know a really
interesting piece in the 30s about
blondal and
holl um there's uh Bernard lonan talks
about
Blondell
um there are um you know a lot of the
newel teoi people are inspired by him
hre dubec for example Le you know major
um he's not a student of Blondell as
such but major interloc and and uh
advancing his ideas within the realm of
theology but also doing a lot of his own
stuff as well um so there's there's
there's a ton of people out there but
you kind of have to like you know look
around to to find them and and sometimes
they won't directly say well this is an
idea inspired by Maurice Blondell I mean
it's interesting because Xavier Ren
calls Blondell the Theologian of Vatican
or the the philosopher of Vatican 2o
because nuil Tei and transcendental
tomis both play an important role and
and Blondell is a major player in both
of those um John you know John Paul II's
fides said
razzio um I want to say that it's uh
it's one of blondell's translators fakra
long who says that while Blondell is not
mentioned in the document the entire
document is blown Deli in in in its
structure and perspective so you know um
there's quite a few people but you kind
of kind of have to dig to to find them
all right
um let's see here so Eric Mets says uh
Jesus says he is the way the truth and
the light nobody gets to the father
except through me seems like an absolute
statement yeah seams is doing a lot of
work there um so I I would say that's a
great example of you doing what we call
Asa Jesus reading stuff in that you want
to find there rather than actually
letting the text speak to you uh you
want to call that absolutist in some
sense of absolute go ahead but um you
know I don't think everybody has to buy
that
um all right hacker own member how much
did you read per day when you're a
student for philosophy I'm self-studying
philosophy and following your lectures
as well just don't know how fast I
should be finishing books there is no
rule for any of that and if if that's
where your attention is you're screwing
yourself
over um you never want to be like saying
I need to read 50 pages a day or
something like that because they're not
comparable to each other you know um
even among literature right so I've got
two books sitting
here
two very different kinds of books the
Phil aalia and that's you know got uh
different people also I'm doing some
work on Maximus the Confessor with a
student so this has theodoris Maximus um
Theos John of damaskin and um um the
Theos and then discourse on ABA filimon
each of these is a different text some
of them read ER some of them read slower
this is a book of fiction uh it's a
slow-going one because it's very dense
um Erikson is is kind of a cool you know
writer that way but this reads a hell of
a lot faster than the filo Kalia you
know so you don't want to be you don't
want to be measuring or assessing
yourself in terms of how much you're
reading per day um livets actually in in
one of his letters to somebody talks
about reading a philosophical book as if
it were a novel like he made his way
through it so quickly different kinds of
literature different authors read at
different Paces so you know there isn't
any any like you should read this amount
per day or anything like that going on
and how much did I read when I was in
college or in graduate school I don't
have a clue I mean I didn't read the
same amount every day um some days I was
doing some things more you know um some
days I was not reading at all
um and I think it's not helpful to to
gauge yourself against other people you
know what you want to gauge yourself
against is how much am I actually
getting out of this text and sometimes
too there's a bit of a side note you
might not get that much out of a text at
the point that you're at like if you
jump right into hegel's phenomenology
which some people think they ought to do
without you know having read a lot of
philosophical literature before that
it's going to be really slow and crappy
going you know and you're probably going
to get discouraged and say I can't
figure out what the hell's going on here
you know um so you know you want to
gauge your abilities to what it is that
you're you're reading
um all right
um let's see
here AE how important do you think
poetic language is to the preservation
of philosophy I don't think it's
important at all um or should a
philosophical work be a strict inquiry
at all times no that's that's not it
either and it's not as if those are the
two choices that that we have
right um all right Von says in a broader
sense of Life how can philosophy help
you instead of ideas like neoism and
Hedonism balancing your mental models
what philosophical ideas can make you
more critically analytically critical
thinker I don't know what an
analytically critical thinker is but um
and you could be a neist and be
analytically critical I imagine in some
sense right or hedonist you could be
like I need to really be critical about
the pleasures and and and uh I pursue
and the pains I avoid so um you know
neoism and Hedonism are philosophical
points of view um the remedy for them is
think your way through them whether
they're really
genuinely uh true or satisfying for you
um you know look at other people who
approach those issues nature can be
helpful in that respect I think you
know
um and Olivia if I recall correctly you
once planned to do a read through of
blondell's action after you finished
Hegel is this still the plan no I talked
about that earlier the plan is next is
anel's prian then decart's medit ations
and I never said I was definitely going
to do blondell's loo I've said I I I'm
thinking about doing core concept videos
which are not the same thing as close
reading videos on blondell's oxio you
know a while back and we'll we'll see if
that
happens
um but if I'm gonna do another big book
it would probably be something that more
people are particularly interested in
you know hegel's phenomenology lot of
people are interested in it that can be
crowdfunded right um because my my time
is
valuable um other works that could be
similarly interesting would be like
sarts being in nothingness or
schopenhauer's will uh world is Will and
and representation or heiger being in
time but I'd be more likely to do sarts
being in
nothingness uh not least because sart is
I mean schopen is a great writer
stylistically but sart's a great writer
as well heiger is not you know so
um all right uh impulsive in the derian
phase video you mentioned wanting to
write a book on 20th century Continental
philosophy is that still on the cards
yeah I mean I I still I'm I've actually
talked with a friend of mine about doing
this together I want to write a book
about um what in 20th century
Continental philosophy turned out to be
silly and what turns out to
be good ideas that we we can use and
there's plenty like with daed there's
plenty of silly that we just
it's not valuable we can leave behind
you know and then there's other things
that are that are more interesting where
we can say okay there's there's
something genuinely here you know
something worthwhile um thinking out so
yeah um but I've got a lot of different
projects in mind and you know um we'll
see which which ones come to fruition
uh L sbg1 when learning a b bunch of how
a bunch of philosophers lived how
exactly how would you do it do you try
to remember their exact birth dates I
don't remember anybody's birth dates or
maybe just the century they lived what's
the most practical here there is no most
practical here this is not people keep
asking about like what's the one way to
do this thing what's the best way to do
this thing there aren't answers to those
sorts of things it depends on you and
the kind of learner that you are and
what for you it's sort of like asking
hey Dr Sadler how do you Journal I don't
Journal ask somebody who does Journal
you know or um how you know like the
reading thing how many pages should you
read a day I don't know depends on you
as a reader you know there there aren't
hard and fast answers for these sorts of
things
um Patrick what do you think of some of
the 20th century analytic philosophers
who seem pretty dismissive of some
questions in Continental philosophy
those who think the meaning of being as
a
nonstarter I think they're kind of
stupid they're smart stupid people you
know and uh why waste time on you know
thinking about smart stupid uh people's
statements just if you want to read
Continental philosophers read those
Continental philosophers or read
analytic philosophers who actually do
take them seriously like Iris Murdoch
and you know John wisdom you know um
there's all there's been a lot of bad
blood between continental and analytic
figures but a lot of that is just a
waste of our time you know life is short
if you want to think things through
there are Myriad thinkers that you could
be spending time on and um seeing if you
can make any advance with
them
um oh Mark says I heard the term skull
activism scholar activism dropped at a
conference recently thoughts on the
term so that's an interesting one
um I guess it would be like scholarly
informed activism or you're you're doing
activism by the kind of scholarhip that
you're you're doing so it's already got
an ambiguity to it doesn't it which you
know philosophy people probably like
because they they like when terms can
mean more than one thing because then
they can unpack it um it doesn't sound
like a very you know it doesn't come off
uh the the tongue like a great term uh
skull activism
I don't see it catching on but I could
be wrong and I when it comes to that
sort of thing you know I'm often wrong
so so I guess we'll we'll see what
happens right
um all right we're getting close we're
at 130 already so let's see uh what we
can finish up
with um calan I'm new to your channel
does philosophy reject the existence of
God it seems like philosophers keep
trying to figure existence out Rebellion
about God well I mean read a bit more
philosophy if that's what you think
because you're going to find lots of
philosophers who think that God exists
so if you're only if your uh general
impression is that philosophers keep
trying to figure existence out in
Rebellion against
God not a hell of a lot of philosophers
who who say that so I'm kind of curious
about who you've restricted your reading
to right
uh Zachary does the unity of the
authentic moral virtues in Aristotle
depend on the single intellectual virtue
of fasis which creates them by
repeatedly choosing the actions that
form them in our character that's part
of the picture but I mean the whole idea
of the unity of the virtues is a red
herring nobody's got the virtues unified
you know and this this you know little
assertion that you know to have one
virtue is to have them all whether it's
an Aristotle or or the stoics go goes so
clearly against our experience and
against so many other philosophers and
against even you know what Aristotle
says in other places and what the stoics
say in other places that it's it's kind
of a waste of our time you're never
going to have a Unity of the virtues I
sure as hell aren't going to and um I
wouldn't worry over much about some
theoretical Sage out there for whom that
might be the case you know prasis is
important but the virtues you know the
the the relationship between the the
virtues and fasis is not that fasis
tells you everything and then the
virtues just go and do it it's they're
peers they're on the same level you know
at least for for Aristotle right for the
stoics virtues are forms of epist but
their knowledge of how to do something
in a certain situation
right
um all right let's see
here
Mickey says do you have or are you
intending to do a lecture series on kamu
the rebel I would love to um that is a
matter of finding the
time um I don't know that I do the whole
of the work because I don't know that
everybody would be quite as I don't know
we get that much mileage out of like
these more obscure authors who nobody
reads anymore and kamu take on them but
I don't know I'd have to think about it
um I think the next thing that I would
do by kamu for well first what I need to
do is I never finished up with the myth
of
Copus so there's a lot of topics within
the work that I haven't actually done
core concept videos on and I'm going to
be teaching that again this this spring
because I'm teaching existentialism so I
gotta I got to finish out that series
first and then I thought you know the
next thing that I would want to do by
kamu is actually letters to a German
friend which I think really great you
know um he's writing to this this German
friend during the middle of World War II
um about the difference between you know
France and Germany and their mindset and
you know being vanquished being the the
conquerors and viewpoints on on Humanity
in it so that that could be quite um
quite worth doing but the rubble is is
very important too I mean a lot of
people they
they read kamu and they're like you know
where the real action is man it's the
stranger and the myth of Copus which
both deal with the Absurd um but the
rebel reworks this notion of the Absurd
you know it's no longer suicide it's
murder that is the question that's
imposed by the Absurd um and so it shows
an evolution and kamu thought and the
stranger is not is not Kam's point of
view on reality Mero is an and
kamu says that he is you know um if we
want to find
kamu the characters who more represent
who who kamu uh wants us to be like I
think we need to look at like the plague
more right
so all right let's see if there's
anybody else Kellan has a
uh uh clarification I was reading Thomas
Nagel as Albert kamu for school research
papers I'm not well read in philosophy
to know every point of view well you
don't need to be well read in philosophy
to read know every point of view nobody
is it's impossible but you certainly can
have read a lot more than just um Thomas
Nagel and Albert kamu if I was gonna
like say give me some representative
philosophers those two sure as hell
wouldn't be it you know um you know you
you want to read uh start start at the
beginning read some Plato you know um
and then see where you go after that
um let's see any other things that I've
missed
here
um again in the
cilic um what do you think of McIntyre's
talk about human dignity do you agree
with him if it's a recent talk I haven't
seen it um so uh I'm but I'm sure you
know given that I've agreed with
McIntyre about a lot of stuff I probably
agree with Him Zachary has a followup
but isn't the unity of the virtues seen
in Zeno no because we don't have Zeno
who held that Temperance courage and
Justice are merely names for Prudence in
different areas of life no that's not
the that's there's a lot of different
things that the stoics say about virtue
don't try to rest it on one single thing
right that's that's a seductive
illusion
um they they all could involve knowledge
but knowledge is not the same thing as
Prudence is not the same thing as wisdom
right so these are it's more complicated
than that but who gives a if the
sto if Zeno said said that what does it
have to do with your question about
Aristotle you always want to avoid
Shifting the ground right uh if you're
asking about X you want to keep asking
about X not secretly be asking about y
that you bring in after somebody um uh
addresses that I was I was just bringing
stoics up as a a stronger example of uh
people who seem to be committed to the
unity of the virtues but in practice
aren't you know nobody exemplifies the
unity of the virtues like I said it's
kind of a red herring you
know
um new joints do you think some physics
and metaphysics by Aristotle would be
ideal to really get into being in time
no there's nothing ideal to get into
being in time and you mean reading
Aristotle's physics and and the
metaphysics sure can't hurt but it isn't
like the her it isn't the hermeneutic C
cue to being in time because you know
you we could just as well say reading
K's first critique or you know hegel's
phenomenology of spirit or pick whatever
else you want I mean haiger is drawing
from all sorts of sources and doing
original work of his own you know so all
right
um let's see here oh Zachary wants to
argue that was a direct quote from DEET
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
right who gives a you know I mean
so your idea here is that you're gonna
like proof text things um it's a direct
quote from introduction to Virtue ethics
insights of the ancient Greeks so you're
relying on a secondary source telling
you what Zeno is saying um and if you I
mean if you really were committed to
saying what we think Zeno might have
said you'd be going to the fragments of
uh the stoics right F arnam uh where if
if anywhere is stuff that might be from
Zeno it'd be in that text you wouldn't
be trying to bring up somebody else's
thing um again this this whole like
Unity of the virtues thing people love
to talk about that sort of thing but
you're not g to get M much mileage out
of it you know you're never going to
realize the unity of the virtues but you
can still be virtuous right so what the
how good does it do you to think that
you know somebody is committed to the
thesis of the unity of the virtues which
by the way nobody in virtue ethics in
actual virtue ethics texts prior to the
20th century ever talked about it that
way you know um that's a sort of like
20th 21st century reconstruction going
back in there um and it's not it's not
very helpful you know so
let's see what else there was one other
one uh oh caldan can you recommend some
awesome philosophy books for a newbie
like me yeah I mean play's dialogues
they're awesome you know they actually
turn people onto
philosophy and get them to start
pursuing it as a discipline and you have
the benefit of like having some really
rich great texts that you can read and
other people have said things about and
other people later on are referencing PL
you know so that could be a really
wonderful starting point I you know when
people ask me where should I begin with
philosophy I almost always say um Plato
why not right it doesn't mean you have
to read everything that Plato wrote but
um why not start there you know it's
it's you know it's a a common reference
point it's not I mean even Whitehead
uh who says you know we could talk about
philosophies being footnotes to Plato he
clarifies that what he means by
footnotes to Plato is Plato gave us raw
material that we can work with and later
philosophers are still exploring some of
these these ideas that that Plato brings
forward so that's a great place to to
begin David says buthus turned me on to
philosophy I mean we all get turned on
in different ways my the first
philosopher who I really like took
seriously and maybe understood to some
degree is probably n right um but we all
come into philosophy in different ways
and there's no one single way to do it
you know Eric met says Plato's Republic
is one of the greatest masterpieces to
ever be written I mean I wouldn't go
that far um but people like it you know
there's many great masterpieces I don't
know that it's among the greatest or
anything like that there's no reason why
we have to be you know that hyperbolic
in Our Praise of of this stuff uh
there's many flaws with the Republic as
well as Aristotle pointed out in in the
Politics as well as in in the ethics
talking about you know the form of the
good um but uh yeah it's a good book you
know I I I don't start people off on the
Republic I start them off on the apology
or the Mino you know or the gorgeous or
stuff like that um I think the Symposium
is better
stylistically you know but uh we all
have different opinions about the these
sorts of things so all right so this is
a great place to end we're about like 12
minutes after the normal time that we
would we would uh finish up so I've
actually got another event to go to
today uh the American philosophical
practitioners Association is going to be
interviewing me as a guest in their Agra
at 3 pm central time so in about an hour
and 15 minutes from now so got to get
something to eat eat and uh you know
check in about that um I'll see you I've
got some other events coming up this
month if you want to participate in them
you can see them in my calendar on
reason io.com or in my Facebook page I
put the events in there so I will see
all of you some other time and uh looks
like we got to almost all of the
questions which is good probably missed
a few here and there but you never you
never get them all so I will see you all
later
on